after weeks of violent attacks by russia
on ukrainian civilians u.s president joe
biden for the first time called russia's
vladimir putin a label that until now
the white house has been hesitant to use
i think he is a war criminal
the president initially avoided the term
given its legal implications and an
official review of putin's actions by
the state department is still incomplete
biden's remarks followed a mourning of
high drama beginning with an emotional
video shared with the u.s congress by
ukraine's president vladimir zielinski
it featured images designed to evoke a
response of what ukraine looked like
just weeks ago before it was attacked by
russia
it was part of the ukrainian president's
virtual plea to u.s lawmakers to do more
to help his country resist russia's
military invasion
remember pearl harbor that terrible
morning of december the 7th 1941.
remember september the 11th
reviving memories of when the united
states was also under attack zielinski
again pressed congress for a no-fly zone
over his country
to create a no-fly zone to save people
is this too much to ask aircraft that
can help ukraine help europe and
zielinski went further appealing to
president joe biden directly even though
biden has already rejected previous
requests
at the leader
of my niche i am addressing
the president biden
you are the leader
of the nation
of your abbreviation
i wish you
to be the leader of the world
being the leader of the world means
to be the leader
of peace
but biden believes a no-fly zone could
lead to a direct confrontation with
russia
and a possible nuclear war he again
resisted zielinski's pleas instead
announcing 800 million in additional
security assistance for ukraine
anti-aircraft and anti-armor systems
small arms and drones more of what the
u.s has already been providing
the united states and our allies and
partners are fully committed to surging
weapons of assistance to the ukrainians
and more will be coming
as we source additional stocks of
equipment that are all that we're ready
to transfer
but the new aid package stops short of
the mig fighter jets and the no-fly zone
zelensky wants putting the white house
and some congressional leaders in
conflict
while i oppose a nato no-fly zone
i support enthusiastically
the sending of mig aircraft from poland
to the ukrainian air force so they can
be more competitive in the skies
well president biden has rejected the
idea of a no-fly zone for now it is
still under
consideration and will undoubtedly be a
topic of discussion when the u.s
president heads to brussels next week
for a special meeting of nato leaders
kimberly hellcat al jazeera the white
house